all right let's see what we find we have
no idea because we have not checked our
bees yet
don't tell the B police
so we have a brand new
set of deep frames
that we might have to replace
oh I need some medium frames in case we
have to take some honey out
let me go grab some medium frames and
then we'll be good to go
you want to go grab this
they're right inside the door of the
barn I had them ready
if all eight frames are full of honey we
will just take the entire box off and
replace it with these deep
but if there's not a lot of honey then
we will only take a little bit of it and
replace it with empty frames we've
actually never done a honey Harvest from
a live Colony so this is
new to us and we're hoping to get some
honey this is their second year so there
should be it should be full of honey and
and I'm hoping that's what I see
but
we don't know yet because we haven't
been in the hives and done an inspection
yet so this is our inspection slash
hunting Harvest if it's available
well I guess it's safe to say that this
is a healthy swarm we caught
they are busy busy bees
all right so we added
another
box
to our swarm hive
and got
a couple of frames of honey from the
other two hives each we didn't want to
take it all so we just took a little
just a sample so we're gonna have some
honey crushing and tasting
[Music]
thank you
are you guys picking strawberries
beautiful ripe organic strawberries how
many have you eaten Daddy
and we just got here
it's probably gonna have more than three
oh more Mama make sure it's red not
white nope nope nope not the white one
gotta pick solid red
daddy you teach them A Little Bit
Stronger
I already told them but
I think he needs reinforcement
not the white one
there's plenty of red ones
are you just eating them instead of
picking
you trying to get Odin to come I mean
you trying to get Liam to come
on Lily
come on wee-wee
hey can I see your fingers
you got a lot of strawberries today
didn't you
mine looked like that too
and your face
so much strawberries let me see you
look at your chin
smile for the camera hi
I have lots of strawberries yeah you do
my heads are red yeah mine too
all right come on
when you're so obsessed with
strawberries that you buy
all of them
[Applause]
[Music]
I absolutely
I absolutely love the diversity of our
Homestead
foreign
all right I decided to pull
some garlic heads to see
because
everybody is having to pull their garlic
early here in Georgia
and
sure enough
so are we
so I'm gonna go ahead and probably pull
all of it I might leave some
but I'm gonna evaluate as I go if I see
one that looks like it's going to be
tiny I might not pull it out
yeah go put them with the garlic
we decided to get a couple of these
extra large onions
to cure
as well so we're gonna put our garlic in
our onions
to dry in the Sun
and then we'll hang them up
to stay dry
watch your step oh you're coming close
to the corner of that
all right put them up here
you want you need some help you do one
at a time
oh okay
yeah you're gonna do that one yeah
oh big boy big helper thank you
so we had a very strange winter
which is the growing season for garlic
so the garlic has had a very abnormal
year for growing and it looks abnormal
we've got some that are huge and already
trying to sprout and grow new heads and
we got some that didn't even divide into
heads that are still really small
well that one's divided yeah that one's
dividing
but garlic goes through like an onion
stage where it's just layers
before it starts to Clove off
like you can tell this bump right here
is in Clove forming on the outside
obviously this one is doing the same
but you just never know what to expect
with your growing season how it's going
to affect the crops you just have to go
with it and for me I decided it was
worth pulling it all the garlic and
having that bed for something else to be
planted into
the guinea have taken quite an interest
in the bunny
champ has a new outdoor
cage so that he can have more space
and more Breeze
we might still put them in our more
protected location
at night but he likes it out here
the American breasts are doing very well
they are upgraded to the chicken tractor
and it looks like we have a good and
taru ratio
so we'll be confirming that as things
get further along but right now it looks
like we have a couple of rooms and a
couple of hens so that's
enough to start breeding them
you got it open uh-huh all right put
that one in there okay
perfect now zip it close
[Music]
so easy a three-year-old can do it
we're gonna use this to dry some of our
herbs
for teas and medicines